I kiss you if it wouldn't kill me
[Applause]
[Music]
patreon sponsor of review time I've got
a few of these actually I'm a little bit
behind trying to catch up on them I'm
working on it everybody I swear so this
time I was commissioned to take a look
at the first two episodes of Pushing
Daisies this was a TV show that lasted I
believe it was two seasons it
unfortunately kind of got badly hit by
the by the writers strike that happened
during its first season which meant its
first season got truncated and by the
time the show got going again it had
kind of lost his momentum and the
ratings weren't there in the second
season which is a shame because it's
pretty dang good here's the thing I
actually had watched Pushing Daisies
back in the day I think I watched the
first five episodes I probably would
have stuck with it beyond that but at
the time I didn't have DVR so if I
wasn't home at the time something aired
I didn't see it so it wasn't a show that
I was prepared to you know ensure in my
schedule that I was home to watch even
though I did enjoy it if I had had DVR I
probably would have stuck with it for as
long it was as it was running um if this
was really cool to go back and revisit
though and kind of remember why I liked
it so much and honestly I really ought
to check out more of Brian fuller stuff
he's the creator of this he also created
wonder Falls which I've never seen he
did Hannibal which have seen and is
amazing and so weird haha and he did the
first seasons of American Gods which I
still need to get around to and Star
Trek discovery which I also need to get
around to but I really enjoy the vibe
that he brings to things he brings a
very at least from the stuff that I've
seen of him a very fairytale kind of
vibe to it and I mean I'm saying that
basic
mostly of this and Hannibal but there's
a very different kind of fairytale vibe
Hannibal feels very much like a Grimm's
fairytale vibe to it you know the the
the darkest most twisted possible thing
that you could have that qualifies it
for a fairytale whereas this has a bit
more of a sweet bedtime story kind of
vibe to it there's a number of things
that that lended that part of its the
narration which is pleasant and
wonderful that actually does that does a
lot to help sell what's going on there's
something about having this nice calm
pleasant voice explain some very weird
concepts and and some of the stranger
backstory points that just makes them go
down better I suppose I should talk
about the premise of this thing which
all right first of all and this is part
of what I mean by like it feels very
fairy tale - because fairy tale esque
it doesn't feel the need to explain
itself so I'm gonna tell you the premise
and how this works and when I do
understand that the show does not
explain why this is the case this just
is how it is and which personally I love
so if you're somebody who need snow wait
a minute
why is that happening this shows
probably not for you you need to be you
need to have a pretty high suspension of
disbelief to roll with the show like
this but I am capable of that and I
actually really like it when things go
for that so premise is we have our lead
character named Ned now Ned when he was
a child
discovered a rather odd ability that he
has which is that if he touches
something like physical contact with
something that is dead that thing will
then come back to life now there's a
couple of caveats to this the first is
if after it has been brought back from
his touch if he ever touches it a second
time it dies again permanently and
cannot be brought back again so that's
the first thing the second thing is if
he doesn't sort of read edify the thing
that he brought back within a minute
then something else in his
proximity has to die basically like I
guess to balance the ledger so if he
doesn't read ed it within a minute
something else will die and I say
something else cuz it's not necessarily
going to be a person we it can be but we
also see instances of birds dropping out
of the sky and and things like that so
it can vary but if if the dead thing is
kept alive something else must die and
again this gets no explanation
whatsoever now that's kind of a business
deal he is partnered with a sort of uh
private detective named Emerson who
basically he he found out what annette
is capable of doing and so he works with
men to basically collect rewards on open
cases you know whenever there's you know
any information provided that leads to a
conviction in this open case there's a
reward they collect those sorts of
things by ned by sort of conning their
way into into the the the morgue
I actually really love the corn I don't
know if he's the corn or the medical
examiner but is this old guy who's just
sort mmm because they they come up with
these ridiculous lies as an excuse to
get in there and look at the bodies and
he's just like wait a minute didn't you
say this last time and that's just like
no mm-hmm but Easter lets them in but
anyway so Ned will touch them basically
ask them hey how'd you die and they and
will then you know they'll use that
information to you know attempt to solve
the situation get a reward
so that's your initial set up so there's
a little bit of a procedural sort of
thing going on there which is kind of a
neat format and then the one other
wrinkle is our third major character who
is Chuck now Chuck is and Chuck is a
girl and Chuck is Ned's childhood
sweetheart when they were both kids like
I mean fairly young they were each
other's first
you know that kind of innocent young
childhood first kiss sort of thing but
Ned accidentally killed Chuck's dad
because at the time when he was good he
did not yet know about the bring
something back and it stays alive for
too long something else has to divert
all he didn't know that was a thing and
so his mother had died I think of an
embolism and he brought her back and
kept her around and then across the
street Chuck's dad drops dead and then
soon after Ned loses his mother anyway
because she goes to kiss him goodnight
that night and immediately dies from
coming into contact with him so the
thing is like on the surface this is
actually like really morbid and like
depressing potentially even except the
show like I said it has such a gentle
touch and the characters are so
endearing and there's sort of this this
slightly just slightly weird
pleasantness to it that that makes it
all work and again I think lends to the
fairy tale kind of feel to it because a
lot of fairy tales are morbid but at the
same time they end with and everyone
lived happily ever after so you're like
oh that was nice but you don't stop and
think about what it was you actually
heard so uh that's that's your core
group of three now the first episode I
did I rewatched the first two episodes
the first episode is it's dealing with
all the the general premise and it is
solving the murder of Chuck because she
did die and Ned brings her back and
keeps her around and but now they both
have feelings for each other and Ned
can't ever touch her again because if he
does she'll drop dead and so that's your
core group of three and and there's just
some really interesting dynamics there I
really do love a more Emerson I love the
actor who plays him I've loved him since
the Somme in the frighteners like back
in the day back in the 90s he's just got
this he's great at this sort of
exasperated yeah kind of kind of feel to
him and I also like they give him a
quirk of being really into knitting like
he's knit little little woolen gun
holster
which I I love those kinds of little
details that are in this and visually
it's really interesting as well I
remember looking it up when it first
aired like thinking was Tim Burton in
some way involved in this because it is
very Tim burton-esque but I want to be
more specific than that because usually
when people think Tim Burton visually
they think you know Beetlejuice they
think you know the the Sleepy Hollow you
know the sort of darker I mean like the
more bright and of Tim Burton I mean
like the stuff set in the suburban parts
for Edward Scissorhands I mean like big
fish I mean like even Willy Wonka Karly
in the Chocolate Factory was his version
so it has that kind of feel to the
visuals which I also think again adds
very much to the atmosphere of the whole
thing as not in any way trying to feel
like it's set in the real world which is
good because none of this is even
vaguely realistic in any way shape or
form we also have a few other cool
supporting characters that I quite
enjoyed there because Ned is actually a
pie maker that is theoretically his day
job he owns a pie shop called the pie
hole
but the reason he hooked up with Emerson
is he he wasn't really making his rent
with that so he does in fact need the
extra money but his his main employee
there played by Kristen Chenoweth has a
massive crush on him which is not
reciprocated I think this might have
actually been the first thing I saw
Kristen Chenoweth in now that I think of
it net also has a dog which was his
childhood dog that he brought back from
the dead and he now can't can't touch
again so like he has the this this sort
of puppet a this puppeted little hand on
a stick that he holds out lights like to
pet the dog because he can't touch the
dog and so there's there's things like
that and the end the guest casts are fun
and the in the murders that they solve
are kind of nuts and ridiculous
including Chuck's chocolate chucks is
kind of ridiculous and we
we get these interesting backstories to
the guest characters in the case of the
very first episode - you know Chuck's
aunts who are involved in sort of
solving everything and then in the
second episode - not only the person who
died but this this other person who had
a relationship with him and that again
very very weird stuff going on but just
presented so matter-of-factly and so
pleasantly this is this is a fairly
union again I don't know how
representative it is of Brian Fuller's
things like I like is that I never saw
Wonderfalls but it's so it might be very
emblematic of what Brian fuller does
overall but for me I I do feel this is a
pretty unique piece of work in terms of
its presentation and the way that it
goes about telling it's incredibly
unusual story but it has its own
wonderful internal logic which is
completely different and distinct and
separate from the earth logic of us
humans but it it does seem very
internally consistent which is something
that I always admire because I love
something that feels like a unique world
not necessarily in the oh we have this
massive show Bible and we've written
these massive expansive backstories for
every character like not necessarily in
that way because I can get kind of dull
encyclopedia but just in the sense of
look the world doesn't work the way that
the world you live in does but you know
it has its own rules and it does this
and presented just very matter-of-factly
I like that when I can find it I don't
find it often enough and I like that
here it's the same kind of thing that I
like about things like labyrinth or the
fall or the fountain you know the things
that don't feel the need to explain
themselves and just kind of are and have
enough respect for the audience that
you'll you'll either go with it or you
won't and if you go with it this really
this really is a great show I can't like
I said I can't vouch for the entirety of
the series I don't know if it ever lost
steam but I do know that it stayed good
for at least the
next three or four episodes after this
because as I said I did watch it back
when originally aired and I remember
liking it but I hadn't heard from anyone
who stuck with it that it got bad only
that the ratings went down and it got
cancelled but if you're into quirky odd
just unusual but pleasant television I
do recommend pushing Daisies
it's it's weird in the best way so that
was that was great to get a to get a
commission for because yes on the
patreon at certain support levels you do
actually get to just flat-out tell me
something to review and I enjoy it cuz
it gets me to either see for the first
time or revisit if I hadn't seen in a
long time stuff that I wouldn't
otherwise be talking about on this
channel and I really do enjoy doing that
so thanks so much for watching Pushing
Daisies first two episodes or your
thoughts on the show as a whole if
you've seen it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
to do buttons links patreon P o box and
all sorts of stuff there's links for all
that stuff down in the description check
it out or also don't if you really don't
want to that's okay I'm not gonna make
you do anything because at the end of
the day folks it's you who are the
council and me I'm just runnin meetings
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]